[Music]
to design a CNC assembly machine
engineers first analyze the sequence of
tasks required to assemble the product
they then match each test to a
pre-designed processing engine the
processing engines are linked together
in a custom assembly sequence the CNC
machines engines are mounted on a sturdy
base frame to construct it workers cut
steel tubes to the required length then
weld the pieces together by melting
steel welding wire into the joints they
bolt a steel tabletop onto the base
frame it has cutouts for each engine
meanwhile an electrical technician is
assembling the machines main control
cabinet it contains one industrial
computer for each engine a CNC machine
has engines for performing rotary
movements linear movements and for
picking up and placing parts once the
main control cabinet is assembled
workers bolted to the base frame some
CNC machines require robotic arms
a computer-guided milling machine cuts
rectangular bars of aluminum shaping
them into robotic arm components after
the aluminum components receive an
anti-corrosion coating workers assemble
them into a robotic arm
these self lubricating sleeve bearings
give the arm the ability to rotate they
add a second assembled arm to create a
pair that works together to perform an
assigned task each engine on the machine
can have up to eight motors the motors
can operate independently or in unison
to test the completed machine a
high-speed video camera captures images
and a thousand frames per second the
quality control team slows down the
video to analyze and fine-tune the
accuracy and efficiency of every motion
[Music]
just a few simple taps on the operators
touch screen can adjust the yarn to move
a millisecond faster or a millimeter
further CNC machines can assemble small
products at high speed they also provide
something traditional assembly equipment
kit flexibility a single machine can be
reprogrammed multiple times for
assembling different products